temps
[Musique]
pour cette présidentielle 2017
il y à une question qui nous taraude
l'esprit et si vous oui vous vous étiez
un candidat à l'élection présidentielle
qu'auriez vous dit pour convaincre les
électeurs début de notre moi président
tour au prêcheur et on peut dire qu'ici
il y a de la suite dans les idées
si jamais je me présente je peux dire
oui j'ai fait ça et puis après je fais
pas à moi président a à jouer mais dit
les autres d'exemple personne donner du
travail aux jeunes du par l'elysée dans
la musique quoi
et côté jeunes on dit quoi à la première
- déjà voir plus de choses pour les
jeunes déjà les jeunes la barre est plus
de travail c'est tout un disent toujours
qu'il faut les jeunes les jeunes mais
quand elles passent président est mobile
et genevois dont la petite pâtisserie du
bourg entre la vente de pains au
chocolat la boulangère préfère plutôt
nous faire part de son exaspération
mais déjà on a plus confiance du tout
alors qu'est-ce que les j'aurais pu dire
qu'est ce que j'aurais pu leur dire
déjà je me serais pas présenté parce
qu'il ya tellement de choses à faire et
que je n'aurais pas pu faire
donc tous ceux qui s'en vont y sont tous
les
les candidats qu'ils représentent pour
moi ce sont des menteurs quoi qu'est ce
que j'aurais dit c'est vrai que vous me
prenez le coup là comme ça en fait
être président de la république je ne
pense pas que vont servir mes cordes
la politique c'est une chose et les gens
qui font de la politique le font pour un
business qu'est le commerce ont fait pas
de la politique pour les hommes on fait
de la politique pour le business
[Musique]
après le prêcheur direction saint pierre
on prend la même question et on
recommence les pires autant ont
semble-t-il pas mal de choses à nous
dire j'aurais dit
plus d'équité c'est à dire que
effectivement pendant la campagne on a
pu constater qu' il ya vraiment une
différence au niveau des rémunérations
etc et que les président et certains
candidats sont vraiment complètement
déconnectés de la réalité
mais je sais pas en fait je sais
vraiment pas parce qu'on est un peu
perdu avec toutes ces histoires de
président donc je sais pas quoi dire
vous n'auriez pas pu dire - président je
vous propose c'est un peu difficile de
dire ça parce qu ils proposent tous des
choses mais sont incapables de les
mettre en pratique
et bien entendu ce mois président tour
ne pouvait pas se finir sans une
proposition phare c'est pas nous qui le
disons c'est monsieur qui le dit la
règle des impôts puis bossa au lac
soutenir les impôts mais c'est ce qu'ils
paient les écoles etc
non il faut trouver d'autres moyens
d'autres moyens pour payer tout ça donc
vous président enlever les épopées par
pinto piano prenez votre temps toute
votre vie à travailler pour construire
une maison et vous payez la maison pour
sa patience voilà c'est dit
prochaine étape de notre tour des
communes à la recherche de réponse à
notre question fort de france
schoelcher une étape riche en émotions -
président moi moi président
ah ah